[GOOGLE JINGLE]
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: It is my
pleasure to hand the mic over
to Dana Gunders.
And welcome.
DANA GUNDERS: Thank you, Scott.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks, everyone.
Do you guys-- do so many
of you seriously think
about food waste every day?
That's kind of amazing.
I like to say, nobody wakes
up in the morning wanting
to waste food that day, but
it just kind of happens.
And that was part
of the reason that I
wrote "The Waste-Free
Kitchen Handbook."
It is so fun to
be here right now.
I've been to Google for
various reasons many times.
And I didn't realize
how fun it was
going to be to be standing
up and not just talking
about a book in a kitchen.
That's great.
Thank you for your time.
I know you have a lot of
important things to do.
So thank you for being here.
What I will first say is
that, unlike many people who
probably give these
talks, I am not a chef.
You may have heard in that bio.
And my background is
released in science.
And so it is kind of
curious that I wound up
writing what some
people call a cookbook.
I don't call it a cookbook.
I like to say it's a
reference book for what
to do in your kitchen when
you're standing there holding
a slightly wrinkled tomato and
don't know what to do with it.
But I really got
into this-- well,
when I was born, actually.
My father was raised
in the Philippines.
My mom grew up in Queens.
Her parents ran a lamp store.
And we're all very frugal.
And so when I was
growing up, I would
be completely embarrassed by
having friends over for dinner.
And my mom would take
the pasta sauce jar.
And she'd put the pasta
sauce on the spaghetti.
And then she would take
water and put it in the jar,
and then shake up the jar,
and pour this watery pasta
sauce on top just
to make sure she
got the last little bits out.
And then we'd sit
down for dinner.
And my dad would
be, like, sucking
the bones of the
chicken and slurping
as he did it just to make
sure he got everything off.
And I kid you not.
Last night, I was
staying with my parents.
And my dad sat down with--
we celebrated Passover
over the weekend.
And so we had all
this turkey left.
And he sat down with a bowl of
bones and started sucking them.
And my daughter sat next to
him and literally started
picking up bones and
sucking them with him.
I was like, oh, this is such
a special moment for me.
So anyway, that's how
it's been bred into me.
And I'm sure many of you have
similar stories somewhere
in your families.
But fast forward--
and for me, it
was really an
embarrassment and not
something I thought much
about until I started
working on a project in the
fruit and vegetable industry
with farmers.
And the project was to
really look at how much water
or how much energy it took--
fertilizer, or pesticide,
and other resources
it took to grow food.
And could we help
those farmers be
a little bit more efficient
with what they were doing?
And as I started to look into
the waste component of that,
I was just startled by the
numbers that I was reading,
numbers like 40% of
food never gets eaten.
Around 20% of the
water in this country
goes to grow food that
never gets eaten--
and similar numbers
around energy,
cropland, and things like that.
Meanwhile, one in eight
people don't have enough food
on their tables all year long--
or at least some
point during the year.
And I just thought,
wow, here we are
trying to get these farmers
to be this much more
efficient with their water.
And yet, no matter
how sustainably we
grow our food, if we're
not actually doing anything
with it at the end and
we're just throwing it out,
it's a huge waste of resources.
And that is what really
impassioned to me on this issue
to the point of
slight obsession.
And I ultimately wrote a report
in 2012 that took on the topic.
I thought it was
just going to be
me and my boss who read it
and maybe one or two people
out there.
And somehow, overnight,
CNN picked it up
on their breaking
news headlines.
I think there was nothing
going on August 23, 2012.
And the next night, I found
myself on "NBC Nightly News"
talking about the issue.
And it's just been wild
to see how much it's
resonated over the last
seven years now with people.
There's just been a steady
stream of interest in it.
It's gone from being ranked as
like a top trend for the food
industry in 2013 to
something that's really,
I would say, become
ingrained as a core pillar
of what a sustainable
food future looks like.
And that's fantastic.
And we have places like
Google taking the issue really
seriously, looking across
all the capabilities here
to think about, how do we make
the food system more efficient?
Because in the end, that's
really what this is.
It's an efficiency question.
And how do we do that?
Now quiz question for you all--
who in the whole supply chain--
when you think about farmers,
grocers, restaurants,
people in their homes--
who wastes the most food?
Let's say, farms.
Raise your you think it's farms.
Raise your hand if you
think it's restaurants.
think it's supermarkets.
Raise your hand if you think
it's people in their homes.
Yes, it is.
People in their homes
make up about 40%
of all that 40% of food
that's getting wasted.
They're a huge contributor.
And it's you and
me standing there
with our overripe
avocado that just
didn't have the same schedule
as our plans that week.
And so that is kind of what
led me to write the book.
Because I felt like--
like I said, nobody
wakes up in the morning
wanting to waste food.
But it's also something we don't
really necessarily think about
in terms of how we're
managing our food.
Are we practicing
the right strategy
so that we don't
get to that point
where there is a
science experiment
in the back of our fridge?
And how do we think about this?
And do we have the right
knowledge of how to use food,
and what can be eaten,
and how to store food
in order to really
make sure we're not
wasting a lot at home?
This is a journey.
In fact, I tell a
little story right
at the beginning about
being at a coffee
shop as I'm writing the book.
And there's a salad that comes
with the sandwich I ordered.
And it is like drenched
in dressing to the point
that I am just not
going to touch it.
And I sat there.
And I was like,
oh, this is ironic.
I am going to waste
half of this plate
while I'm writing a book to tell
everybody not to waste food.
Isn't that funny?
But it really reminded
me to let everyone know
this is not about perfection.
And the great thing
is that every time you
take a little step
to waste less food,
it lowers the demand for food
out there just that much.
And I think that really gets at
what the size of the prize is.
So by 2050, it's estimated
that we will need up
to twice as much food
to feed a growing
population and a
population that is starting
to eat more resource-intensive
foods like meat and dairy
in other parts of the world.
And so where's that
food going to come from?
That's a huge-- food already
takes up an enormous portion
of all of our land.
Are we going to cut
down more rain forests
and grasslands in order to
plant more food to get that?
Or are we going to
just start being
more efficient with the food
we have and actually using it?
And that means finding
ways to really build
in a more streamlined
system for our food,
as well as looking at how
some of the foods that
are being grown are being
used, such as feed for animals.
And are there ways to better
use that land to grow foods
that we eat directly?
So with that, we have a
couple of fun recipes.
So the book has some strategies.
And then it has some recipes.
And then it has my favorite
section in the back, which--
I call it the directory.
And it has 85-plus foods.
And it gives you information
on whether or not
you can eat the
stalk of a broccoli,
or a banana if it
has brown spots,
or an apple if it gets a
little bit mushy, or something.
So you can look
up foods and learn
how you should store it, about
how long they last, the best
way to freeze it, and then
little things about what parts
are edible, and how you
know if it's still good.
But the recipe part is
not your average cookbook.
It really tries to find
things in the kitchen that
often do get thrown out, and
think about ways to use them.
So today, we're going to
learn two of those recipes.
The first is going to
be broccoli stalk salad.
Has anyone ever cut off
this part of a broccoli
and thrown it in the
garbage or compost?
I see a lot of nodding heads.
It's totally edible.
And it's delicious.
It's sometimes even sweeter
than the floret part.
And so there is a recipe that
we're going to make today
called broccoli stalk salad.
And there's a couple
of things to know.
One is, depending how
strong your teeth are,
this part at the bottom
is usually pretty tough.
So that very part of the bottom,
you might want to cut off.
The outer skin of
the stalk-- and I
think this is probably why
it's sort of gone out of favor.
The outer skin can be
kind of tough and almost
too fibrous to really chew.
So when you're
making this salad,
you do want to peel that off.
I think I was supposed
to do it into this bowl.
Now if you are too lazy
or too rushed to do that,
there's another
way you can do it.
And you lose a
little bit more trim.
But if you just
kind of square it--
this is what I do sometimes when
my two-year-old is screaming--
you can also do a little square,
and cut all these those outer
tough parts off.
Or if you're up
for the challenge,
you can also leave them on and
have it be slightly chewier,
as well.
So do that.
I'm not sure where to put the--
oh, I'll just put it there.
And then from there, this
is really a basic salad.
So we're just-- you
can use a peeler
and sort of julienne
the broccoli
into the bowl like that.
If you prefer to be a
chopper, you can chop it up
into little disks like this.
You can sort of
do it into lines.
It doesn't really matter.
And kind of mix it up.
But I'll keep doing
this for a moment.
And the other
thing is, sometimes
if you only have one or two--
like, if you just buy
a bunch of broccoli
and you just have
one bunch, then
you don't necessarily
have enough stalks to make
a salad like this.
You can just chop
it up and throw it
into whatever you're
doing with the broccoli.
You're making a stir fry, chop
it up, put it in the stir fry.
You're just steaming broccoli,
just cut it down to those ends.
Eat those stems.
There's really no reason not to.
And one other thing I
like to do is use it
as a substitute for celery.
Because I find that celery
is something that gets
sold in a bunch that
I don't typically use.
But we go through a lot
of broccoli in my house.
And so instead, I'll
substitute broccoli stalk
for celery in, say, a soup
recipe or something where
it's cooked.
It has not exactly
the same flavor.
But like I said, I'm not a chef.
I'm not looking for perfection
in my kitchen all the time.
And so that seems
to work just fine.
OK, so you do that.
And then we're just going to
make it a little bit in here.
So the next
ingredient is carrots.
You might find this
a little crazy.
I just skip peeling the carrots.
Carrots-- you wash
them, their roots.
They're not any dirtier on the
outside than any other food
that you might eat directly.
And so you can just put them in.
And put them right in.
It's less to throw out,
more salad for everyone.
So that is what we
do with the carrot.
All right.
Next, we have onions.
And cut the onions off.
What do we do with these onions?
Anyone have any
idea what they could
do with this part of onion?
AUDIENCE: I usually freeze
mine for vegetable stock.
DANA GUNDERS: All right.
I do the same thing.
Freeze them.
Make vegetable stock.
They make a great vegetable
stock, especially when you
do have a lot of onions in it.
Another interesting
thing about onions
is that the peels can
be used to make a dye.
It's Easter, and
there are actually
a lot of natural dye recipes
out there using red onions
and their peels, in particular.
So we will do that.
Chop it up a bit.
Put that in there.
And then we can throw
in some avocado.
Now, we'll be
talking about avocado
for our second recipe
today even more,
which is chocolate
avocado mousse made
with overripe avocados.
But for this salad,
just chop it in.
It makes it kind of creamy.
And we are set there.
Dressing-- super basic.
You guys are going to be
surprised at how delicious this
actually is.
And though I'm not
a cook, I did have
some help from
some professionals
in developing the recipes
that are in the book.
So I am a cook.
I'm not a chef.
So we have olive oil,
red wine vinegar, agave--
you can also use honey.
We used agave to make
sure this would be vegan
for any vegans in the room--
and some salt. And that's it.
And we mix it up.
I'm going to put a portion in--
not too much.
And just chop a
little parsley on top.
The parsley that we're using--
turns out, it comes
with some stems--
totally edible,
totally able to be
thrown in if you're putting
them in the food processor
or with anything.
I chop them up and just use
them in whatever I'm doing.
Other people may just want to
use the leaves for something
like garnish.
But then you can use the
stems and stalk just mixed
into any kind of salad.
So throw those in on
top, and mix it up.
And we're going to get to
try this in a little bit.
It's best if you let
it sit for a while.
Because it softens the
broccoli up and just
marinates it a little bit.
So that's that.
Any questions there?
Do you guys use broccoli stalks?
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
Yeah, I'm hoping
she's going to plate
that, so we can see it.
Yeah, so in our operation,
which is a little larger
than cooking for four, or
five, or six people at home,
we would have large machines
like this that would basically
do all that prep for us.
But I love the point about--
a lot of vegetables you
may not have to peel.
And if you are peeling them,
a lot of these byproducts,
like the onion skin, can
be used in so many things.
And so we would do
the same approach.
And so the carrots--
most of our chefs don't
peel carrots anymore here.
We actually just put out
a little piece on this
to Googlers that, when you're
peeling away the fiber,
you're losing some of
that nutrient, as well
as the textural fiber.
So leaving it on there--
as long as it's cooked in
a proper way in the way
that you slice it
super thin, it's still
going to be super delicious.
And so we're doing a
lot of the same things
you're talking about but
at a much larger scale.
So it's great to see.
DANA GUNDERS: There's kind of
this mantra in the food waste
world, if you will, that is
similar to if you've ever heard
of "reduce, reuse, recycle."
It's similar to that.
We like to think about
it the same for food
but with some nuances.
But the first tenet is let's
try to not have extra food.
Let's try to not
have food scraps.
Let's try to use it all
food as much as we can.
And for the home cook, that is
partially about how you shop,
actually.
Because when you're
shopping, that's
when you're making the
commitment to food.
So if you planned your
meals really well,
if you have made
a shopping list--
you've actually stuck
to your shopping list--
that helps you manage your food.
Because it's really about how
you're managing your food.
And it helps you not
wind up in that place
where you just bought
something on a whim
and didn't get
around to using it.
And part of it is also
being able to use up
most of the vegetable.
You sometimes hear
people talking about nose
to tail cooking
for meat and trying
to use up all of the animal.
Well, it's kind of the
same thing in fruits
and vegetables-- is a root
to stalk, they call it--
and really trying to
use the whole thing.
So things like beets, if
you buy them in a bunch,
you can actually use
those beet greens.
Cut them up, and saute them.
It's like a two
for one in my book.
I just heard someone
the other day say,
carrot greens are going
to be the new parsley.
And you can use those, as well.
So there's a lot
of little things
you can do to just
make more of what
you're using in the kitchen.
And I have to say, this topic
have been amazingly resonant
with people, just these
like tips and tricks on,
how do you use stuff?
How do you store your food?
I have found that it's a
topic that keeps giving.
And people are really
constantly trying
to learn and do a little
bit better in their kitchen.
There's a lot of
curiosity around it.
All right, so let's go forth,
and make some chocolate
mousse using overripe avocados.
We're going to move over here.
I would like to pass this
around real quickly, actually.
We'll do one this
way and one this way.
Check out the avocados
we're going to use today.
And tell me what
you would normally
do with an avocado like that.
If anyone says, guacamole, first
of all, I don't believe you.
Second of all, I
think that guacamole
using overripe avocados
tastes a little funny.
That's the thing about
overripe avocados.
They have a little
bit of a funky taste.
And the other thing
about avocados
is they're really hard to nail
in that perfect window of time.
You buy it, it's so hard.
And then you do stuff,
like live your life.
And then you come home, and then
you're like, ugh, I missed it.
Has anyone ever had that happen
to them on their $2.00 avocado
or $1.50.
So when I discovered
this recipe,
I was so excited about it.
Because, well,
you're going to see.
It's amazing in
how well it hides
that funky, overripe
flavor of avocados.
Now, are any of you
frightened to eat this?
All right, bold people here.
But a lot of people are.
So a lot of people pick up
an avocado that is this mushy
and feel like, this is bad.
This is bad.
And I don't know
if I can eat it.
And I think what's
behind that is, is it
going to make me sick?
So this is actually, I think,
a really important thing
to understand when
you're in your kitchen.
Because we all have that
moment where we're like,
can I eat this?
Is this going to make me sick?
And here's what I want
to tell you about that.
People get sick from food
because it's contaminated.
So you hear about people
getting sick from E. coli,
from salmonella, from Listeria.
Those are all what they
call foodborne illnesses
from pathogens, which are
bacteria that get on the food
before it's entered your mouth.
Oftentimes, it gets on
the food at the farm,
at the processing plant,
somewhere along the way
before it's gotten to you.
What makes food old
and what makes it
decay are totally different
bacteria and actually
a lot of enzymes
which are not bacteria
but sort of natural protein--
I don't know what enzymes
are-- but natural things
in the food that break it down.
Those bacteria and enzymes
that break food down
are not what make people sick.
And so there's kind
of this mass fear
around old food in our country
that is leading a lot of food
to be thrown out.
And when you look
at the date labels--
we see this happening around
the dates that are on food.
And you'll see best by,
sell by, use by dates.
Does anyone want to take a
guess at what those mean?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Isn't it when the
store has to sell it by,
and then it has to
go off their shelf?
But it doesn't mean you
can't use it at home.
DANA GUNDERS: OK, that's good.
So when the store has to sell
it by to get it home to you
with enough time so that you
can actually use it and have
a good experience with it.
That is true for sell by
dates that actually say
the words "sell by" on them.
And then we see others that
say "use by" and "best by."
Who wants to take a guess?
I saw a hand over here.
So it turns out that
used by and best
by dates-- first of all, none
of them are federally regulated.
The only product
that is federally
regulated around these
dates is infant formula,
which has a use by date,
because the nutrients can
decline over time.
And they want to make sure
that the infants are getting
the appropriate nutrients.
Other than that, those
dates are actually
manufacturers' estimate--
so their best guess--
at when the product is at
its top quality or freshness.
And so if you have a
yogurt, for instance,
the way a company might
come to that date is
to take a bunch of
consumers, a focus group,
put them in a
room, and give them
five-day-old yogurt,
eight-day-old yogurt,
10-day-old yogurt
and say, OK, rate
this on a scale of 1 to 10.
And as yogurt gets older, when
the score drops to below a 7,
let's just say, that's the
date that they do it on.
And so it's really about, is
the texture-- or sometimes
it's, does the texture change?
But those dates are actually
not meant to indicate the food
safety, or to tell
you that it's bad,
or it should be thrown
out on that date.
The vast majority
of them are really
just trying to tell you
that this product is
at its top quality and I,
the brand, stand by it.
And so one of the things that I
really try to dispel out there
is the fear of food that
exists about it going bad.
And one of the
ways we do that is
to make delicious
overripe avocado pudding.
So hopefully, I
have not scared you.
And what's awesome is
this is super easy.
If you only have one overripe
avocado-- this is with two--
you can actually just
do this in a bowl
if you don't have
a food processor.
And just mash it up.
And that actually
works, as well.
So I'm going take that out.
Scoop it in.
There's also some neat products
coming out that are natural
coatings-- and they've
started with avocados--
to actually make the life
during which it's ripe,
that period of time for
which it's ripe longer,
which I find fascinating.
And it just slows the ripening
process down a little bit.
All right, take that out.
And then all we're going
to add is some cocoa
powder, agave syrup--
you can also use
maple syrup or honey.
Honey changes the
flavor a little bit--
and salt, vanilla,
milk of your choice,
be it cow or some
kind of alternative.
This is pea milk that
we are using today
to keep it vegan
for anyone who is.
Put it in there.
When I did my book
tour, I tried to make
this in a few different places.
And we had one that was
quite a large audience.
And we had to find, like,
50 overripe avocados, which
is not an easy thing to do.
Because we had to go to,
like, five different stories
and beg them to give us
their overripe avocados.
Let's see if that's done it.
Yep, I think we're there.
All right, and
there you have it.
We'll get to try this soon--
delicious avocado mousse.
Also, what I love about
this recipe is it's vegan.
It is also way healthier than
throwing the usual butter
and cream that you would
into a chocolate mousse.
So it's an added benefit.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Awesome.
We've done some taste tests with
some chefs on this dish before.
And many of them
couldn't tell that it
didn't have the cream in it.
They knew something
was different.
But they couldn't
tell that they didn't
have the actual fat, because the
avocado did a great job of it.
It's a really good dish.
DANA GUNDERS: Yeah, I can't
wait for you guys to try it.
And we are actually going to
try it with strawberries today.
And what I want you to know,
should you care to try this,
is that the green parts
on strawberries-- this
was like the very
last fact that I
had to verify before sending
my book to the publisher.
And I did so by talking to
the California Strawberry
Commission.
And the green parts on
strawberries are, in fact,
edible.
They're a little bit chewy,
but I welcome you to try it.
Their texture is not
ideal for eating.
But I think it comes
very much in handy
when you're making smoothies.
Because it takes a lot of work.
If you're doing it with
fresh strawberries,
you can just throw
them in, blend it,
and you won't notice
the difference--
get a little extra
vitamins in there for you.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Awesome.
So first off, big
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
We're not done yet.
So the chefs in the back are
putting both of these dishes
together for everyone to sample.
So my first question
is, you have obviously
thought this through.
You've wrote a book on it.
You've got all the
tips in your head.
How do you bring others along?
So, say you've got a
friend, a spouse that
just doesn't think about it.
What's been successful?
And maybe toddlers
aren't the best example,
because you can
kind of mold them.
But what's been the
best example in trying
to get others to think
differently about what you're
so passionate about?
DANA GUNDERS: That's
a great question.
What I have found is
that people naturally
don't want to see
food going to waste.
There's something
instinctive or something.
And so when I first
got into this topic,
I was really surprised
by how much it
was resonating with everyone.
And then I just tuned
into that, that people
don't like food to get wasted.
However-- so getting them
to care is not that hard.
But getting them to notice
is what's really hard.
Because we are not
wasting 40% of our food
in one big chunk over here.
And you're not throwing all
your food out in your home
at one time in the year.
It's happening every
day a little bit.
It's scraping your plate off.
It's not touching the potatoes
on a breakfast platter
that you go out to for brunch.
It's just cleaning out
your fridge here and there.
And so it's really hard to see.
And so I think the
two things that
have worked-- one is really
talking about this food safety
issue and getting people to
understand and be a little less
afraid of their food
by understanding
the science behind food.
What really is going on
there that could make you
sick or not?
And therefore, empowering
people to cook and try things
that they maybe
didn't try before.
I think the other is--
I have found that it
is kind of entering
the ethos a little bit.
And I think that
we're really going
to win when it is very
uncool to throw food out.
That, to me, is going
to be the big engine.
So I see it in my life-- since
you asked about my life--
because people are afraid
to eat dinner with me.
Because they sit down at dinner.
They don't think
about it before.
And then they sit down.
And they're like, oh,
am I going to have
to finish this plate
of food, because I'm
having dinner with you?
And so I see that
cultural, that sort
of social pressure that
I think is actually
really effective on this topic.
And I always say, hey,
I'm not the food police.
We'll get a leftover box.
It's OK.
And then we go back
to it being a journey.
I think what's really
helpful on this topic
is seeing the fun in it.
Because there's a lot of fun
in learning new tips and tricks
and just becoming more
familiar with food.
And so I think finding the
fun in it keeps it alive.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: I like
your example a lot better.
In a lot of kitchens--
not at Google
but in a lot of
kitchens-- you are first
learned how to combat food waste
when the chef walks up, takes
the garbage can that you put
all your food trimmings in,
dumps it upside down, and
makes an example of you.
It happened to me once.
I was very young.
It stuck.
DANA GUNDERS: I can't tell you
how many people come up to me
and go, oh, my god, I
thought of you the other day.
I had this almost rotten tomato.
And I threw it in a pasta sauce.
I'm like, great.
I'm like the queen of
rotten tomatoes here.
That's actually like--
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
That's awesome.
So we have a few minutes for
questions from the audience.
I'd love to hear anything
that's on your mind.
If you don't have questions, I
might have questions for you.
And the question might
be, what is the one tip
that you do at home that's been
successful in combating waste?
Like, you're going to the
big box stores less often,
and shopping more often per
week-- things like that.
So if you don't have questions,
I might come back to you.
So raise the hands.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
DANA GUNDERS: Yeah.
You can answer that, too, Scott.
So the question was,
what works better?
Is it letting people serve
themselves or pre-plating food,
in terms of waste?
I think the closer we can get
to letting people customize
their plate for what they
want, the better we're doing,
the less likely it is that
they'll waste something.
So in a home setting,
I think, certainly,
letting people serve
themselves can be better.
I know there's been a lot of
thought behind this at Google.
So I'll let you answer it on--
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Yeah, it's
a really complicated question.
And we look at a lot of the
things that we focus on.
There's food waste at Google.
There is line throughput.
There's portion control.
There's balance.
There's all of these.
We find it quicker
and more effective
and overall appealing
to the users
if we actually plate the food--
but the caveat of having
a conversation to see,
would you like more or
less of this or that?
And can have the conversation.
But to Dana's point, if you
can ensure that people are only
getting what they want in the
exact amounts, that's great.
Part of the problem
here that we have is
there's so much variety.
The more you see,
the more you might
want to put on your plate.
And then you get to
the point of there
might be too many offerings.
So I would say that another
great tip is really be
mindful of how much
variety you have.
Because the more you
offer, the more people
want to try all the good stuff.
DANA GUNDERS: Yeah,
that is absolutely true.
I think when you really peel
back the layers on this topic,
you get down to a few themes.
One is portions.
So quick pop quiz here--
how much have the calories in
the average cookie increased
since the 1980s?
Anyone-- doubled, tripled, more?
They've actually quadrupled in
calories, the average cookie.
And the average Caesar
salad has doubled.
So our portions have
increased tremendously.
We have this mindset
that quantity
is value as a general
thing in our country.
And that is leading
to waste-- so portion.
But then variety
is another thing.
We really want choice.
And there's a PhD
student who did
some interviewing of people.
And she said, hey, if
you brought eggs home
from the store and you
dropped them on the floor,
how would that make you feel
as you're putting them away?
And of course, everybody
felt very upset about that.
And then she said, hey, if you
don't drop them on the floor,
you put them in
your refrigerator.
And four weeks later,
you get to them,
and they're not good anymore.
But you haven't
eaten any of them.
How do you feel about that?
And they felt less
bad on the scale.
And I think that's
really fascinating.
Because I think behind
that is something
around having the
option to eat something.
So I think we want to have
our options when we want them.
And we also want a lot of them.
And that's true in our homes.
So we have more food our fridge
than we actually are eating.
That's also true in a
grocery store, where
they have to carry like
50,000 different items
so that we can walk in and
pick which kind of cereal
we want out of an entire aisle.
And it's also true in
restaurants, where there's
a pressure to have a
pretty big variety of foods
and a big menu.
And that makes up
a little bit harder
to do all their stocking,
and inventory, and things.
So I do think the
variety and choice
thing is an underlying driver.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Excellent.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
DANA GUNDERS: Yeah,
great question.
The question was,
are there any efforts
to reduce portion sizes, given
that we're not that active?
We don't actually need as
much as a lot of people
are eating in the country.
There is a lot of attention
to that, particularly because
of the health components of it--
the increased calories and all
the health effects of that.
And here in California,
there's a law
around posting the calories.
You may have seen,
different like fast food
restaurants or restaurants
of a certain size
need to post their calories.
That's been one policy
effort towards that.
I think there is a lot more we
could do-- is what I could say.
There are people
thinking about it.
We have dietary
guidelines about it.
But in terms of what impacts
you when you pick up a plate,
and put food on it,
and how much you eat,
I think there's actually some
innovative stuff that could be
done to change habits in place.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
So real quickly,
what we've been doing
for several years--
probably going on four,
close to five years
through this current
system, but we
were doing it previously-- is we
have a system that we partnered
with.
It's called LeanPath.
And imagine a scale and a
camera that is in your kitchen
that, every time you
have some trim left over,
you can take a picture of it.
And what that data does is it
allows you to look at, over
the course of a day, a week,
a month, a year, whatever--
through the 70-plus cafes
we have in the Bay Area,
there's a lot of food--
where we have
potential opportunities
for overproduction.
Are we making too much?
Are we buying things that maybe
could come in already peeled,
so we're not throwing
that in the compost?
And all of that data, over time,
allows us to basically menu
smarter so that we're able to do
a repetitive cycle menu, which
means that, in any
cafe you're in,
that menu will run for
probably about three weeks.
And then it will repeat.
And so the chefs
now have a rhythm,
knowing that every
three weeks they're
going to make that recipe a
little bit better, a little bit
tastier, and they're going
to be a little less wasteful.
And I'm happy to say that the
Bay Area, for the last probably
three quarters, has
achieved all of their KPIs.
And they just won the
Sustainability Award
at Environment Day based
off of their efforts
around food waste.
We have a long way to go
in other aspects of Google.
Imagine all the stuff
that we take back
to our desks and things that
don't make it to the cafe waste
stream--
but overall, doing
an amazing job.
And it's folks like Dana
and people like you that
are asking those questions.
We all need to continue
to think that through.
Because it's not just
a waste of the product,
but it's a waste of the
time of all of our chefs
that have made that food that
we then end up throwing out
for all of the "right
reasons" at that moment-- so,
good question.
DANA GUNDERS: Yeah,
that's a great question.
The question was around schools.
Schools are complicated.
Because of the federal funding
that happens for school lunch,
there's a requirement
to at least offer
a certain amount of food and
certain different quantities.
And different schools interpret
that a little bit differently.
There are a lot of people
thinking about this.
So what you have are
you have kids going
through the school lunch line.
They take a milk.
They literally don't
touch that carton of milk.
They feel like they
have to take it,
or the lunch lady is telling
them they have to take it.
And then it goes
straight in the garbage.
Because they're not even allowed
to share it with anybody else.
And at that very
same school, you
have 80%, 90% students
who are low income enough
to be qualifying for the free
and reduced lunch programs.
And some of them likely
don't necessarily
have a steady supply of food
to their tables all year.
So it's a real conundrum.
And I'll tell you,
what's happening on
that front is that
there is a lot of push
for schools to understand they
only have to offer the food.
They don't actually
have to serve it.
So students don't always
have to take all of the food.
They have to be given
the opportunity.
There's a lot of work
on share tables--
so places where students,
if they do take food
and they don't touch it, they
can put it on that table,
and others can take it.
And there's some work on how
to send food home with students
at the end of the
day or week that
could help with that, as well.
So yeah, it's a real
opportunity area, I think.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
A huge, again,
round of applause for Dana.
Thank you very much.
Great job.
DANA GUNDERS: Thanks
for having me.